that was the worst is it ready hello I
think I might be sick
it is 6:30 in the morning I feel like I
barely slept at all last night I woke up
and I honestly thought it was a cruel
joke I'm very tired
everything is packed we've got all the
stuff honey for the race we've got spare
changing clothes afterwards
we've got like half an hour to get some
breakfast now and then we are driving
off to Cambridge it's still not really
awake at the moment I still didn't
really feel like I'm going to go and run
13 miles I'm one of these people who
really struggles to have breakfast
Norway so I'm forcing myself to have a
bit more than I normally would hopefully
early enough that it's not gonna be a
problem
okay made it still raining t-minus
roughly an hour we just got the bus to
the sort of mouthing start which is just
over here definitely the range you used
to be Stephanie makes it feel a bit
better but I am definitely feeling just
nervous I just want to start at this
point there is also the small matter of
putting on the costume in not very long
in front of in front of a lot of people
this is you paid for this
[Music]
does feel like walking to the festival
[Music]
the great thing about my training runs
is that I've won every single one of
them I don't think I'm gonna be coming
first today
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
so quickly in the costume we've had like
five fever laughing already
at least five people of enjoyed I don't
think it's gonna affect my running if
anything the house actually just keeping
my head warm it's quite cold okay
walking over to the pens now they're
releasing us in waves I'm in pink wave
okay final thoughts before the start of
the race so there's about 15 minutes
until I think my wave goes the first
people are running are lining up over
there at this point I definitely felt
like I got the energy like the
enthusiasm has definitely caught back up
with me
think I'm ready I think I'm ready I just
I'm just anxious to get his first miles
down at a slow enough to not self too
far so I can hear about six kilometers
six minutes per kilometer then that's
can he beat you for about the first by
UK by will yeah about that and then
we'll open up the taps a little bit I've
got to pace myself
[Music]
the previous pens have gone up the fast
runners have already gone now we're
styling up to the line okay here we go
okay want one that's good
[Applause]
[Music]
- half KN sorry 1/2 k1 one and a half
miles grant Tsubasa as I knew I would
so I'm gonna counter said let's try to
slow down a bit it's difficult when
there are so many people cheering you on
okay it's the street I'll line with
people there were people do an impromptu
music if you were covered in getting
hugs and high-fives it's a great can you
know now okay so have a focus slide out
to say that
[Music]
so don't Lee one of the worst bits of
this half mountain is the scenery are
surrounded with I mean that's gone
blinkie's college behind me it looks
like someone would stick on a pile of
concrete Senate houses all right I
suppose I mean I think it's a bit much
over the top just past month for I did
sell too fast because now it's about
that selling of a stage so I'm dropping
back to what was meant to be my starting
pace hit this for a couple of months
just stabilized I've had this before in
training runs my 21st just got to drop
back a little bit cats be in the end I
slowing down now I'm being faster ever
[Music]
okay here it is this is the turn this is
like they're going to us the farm part
of the course now
the space has definite got better I just
want to hold back and pace a little bit
longer just to make sure I'm not gonna
wreck myself that's just over halfway
Shanthi out to the angels who were given
out jelly babies back I didn't have a
chance to ask you vegetarian so I'm just
gonna shoot really were had a nice chat
with the guys about a minute behind me
swapping stories about why we were
running you know what's how do you owe
me for think I seriously but very nice
guy shows everybody here has got their
own individual story everyone hears
raising money plumpy
a lot of people hinted I think I just
like it
oh sweet
let's go 60 miles now now three cores
will be ready - coming back into the
center of town it's all starting to feel
very familiar now as in film at the ends
not too far away
miss Tilly is still miles away but it
feels like it's all far away
back in the sensor running through the
favela of Cambridge
it's horrible around here just past mile
10 any of 5kc goes in your Park right
now turn fact this is called orgasm
bridge as police lack flavor it's now
that you may recognize the street some
around here have you seen the theory of
everything this is where they cyclist
started young
cabeza that's my heart
definitely sorry fella station
so close now
[Music]
final model
this is really hard now faster
this is someone I think it's just
fantastic
[Music]
we did well I think he got on this job
that was the worst is it buddy oh I
think I might be sick I'm not going to
say I'm not gonna say just so over the
glaybels time for two hours I started
before them so I'm not sure what time
thou be'st actually pays his summer stop
okay
the Cory's my straw that was 154
quite a bit better than I expected why I
wanted to do two hours if I done 155
would have been really happy you say
nice that's fantastic I misjudged the
final sprint I full sprinted up to about
under me is my mind and my legs gave out
so I did like okay I need some bug fix a
girl someone needs a very sweaty hug
thank you very much
oh my strawberry I may have missed your
finish it felt great
yeah right at the end I think it was
like mile 13 basically I was like I
sprinted and I finished up my sprint
about a hundred meters too short
so we're in Boots just getting some
sweets for the journey on the way back
because I have like 4,000 calories to
eat today and Pixar though just like it
to be known that she's very sore
she's how your legs are they okay you
went 5k yes this is quite bad okay so
it's the day after the marathon the half
marathon
I had intended on doing this bit to
camera yesterday but I was gonna be
going through the bag we're gonna have a
race hall and I wanted to talk about
sort of like a retrospective I was too
tired for some reason let's have a look
at what the hang on let's have a look at
what they give you this is my haul from
running 13.1 miles we oh oh that smells
quite bad there the packet of quavers
rogue choice big fat wave oh they popped
a guy that was what that pop was we've
got my running thing which I popped in
here yesterday all of this stuff by the
way
reeks a thing of water probably should
have drunk that yesterday
after run instead of just having a beer
alcohol-free beer mine indian-inspired
nimbu pani lemon cumin and mint still
that would've been really nice yesterday
is this equal to vegetarians yes a
Weetabix on the go strawberry beta
glucans an elderberry immune complex
also suitable for vegetarians I haven't
no I I know that if I'm pregnant not
supposed to take this Clark's maple
syrup it's me I wonder if that was like
what I was on that they had these energy
things only I had one of them on the
course because I was worried about
upsetting my stomach and it was actually
really nice I this is like it feels like
one of those energy packs there's that
nut bar a banana I was quick an ultimate
blends with argan oil something a bunch
of quavers and a thing from cancer
research oh it's one the specialist one
their laces yeah like pink lace that's
definitely an improvement from last year
and the pixel veil got like a razor in
hers for some reason I really hope it
was supposed to be in there general
thoughts on yesterday though it was one
of the most incredible things about were
done it was one of the most lovely
experiences seeing a bunch of humans
come together there's all these people
who would look I said in the run were
fundraising you look all these people
were raising money for charity I mean
not all of them some of them were
athletes but a lot of us I think they
said there was gonna be a quarter of
million pounds raised for just four
counts of research yesterday all these
incredible people running and then also
all the people supporting all the people
who were just giving out sweets and
giving out jelly babies and they were
the entire way around the course there
was probably less than 500 meters across
the entire course where there wasn't a
supporter you know that was a further
she'd have to go to get a boost of
people and the fact that you have your
name like on your badge like on your
name like it wasn't a name plate the
people were just picking out people's
names be like yes I'm go come on in and
like that I did it once does a guy I
think it's like Matt or something it was
like at my old 11 just next to me this
guy can like pulls off and is like Oh
anymore whose turn around and feel like
God that you could do it but all the
people on the side were incredible my
favorite way to people
my two favorite people were one the guy
who had a college room above one of the
robe shops in Cambridge when it was like
a corner that you went around in the
half he just opened a whole of his
windows and was blaring music out as
loud as he possibly could just to act as
like a deity was DJing in the window
absolute lad the other was the little
boy who everyone else was giving out
sweets was giving out like I say they
were part there must have been like 20
to 30 people around the whole course
they were just just giving away sweets
and there was this one little boy he was
about seven or eight maybe who had a
thing of ready salted crisps and no one
was eating them and I felt really bad
for him so I had some and then my mouth
immediately dried up I don't remember
it's what I why the runners probably
weren't eating crisps it's fine I just
had some jelly babies after that just to
get kind of wash it wash it down oh yeah
it was incredible it was absolutely
remarkable
I'm also very like I don't get I'm not
proud of really of anything I've done
but I am I'm replays by my time I was
shooting for sub 2hours if I was gonna
get under 155 that would have been
amazing which I did that you know I was
not expecting that
a genuine he wasn't expecting that it
does make me think that maybe I can make
it under 150 for the for the one in two
weeks because ultimately this is only
the first half I've got to do the second
half of the marathon now but that is now
a target I've got something I want to
definitely try and repeat this time no I
doubt I'm gonna have the same support
from like around the sides and people
cheering people you know the whole mass
of people on but I think I can do it in
that time again I think I can go faster
so I have to see as a general review
though amazing event really really
enjoyed doing it was very well organised
you knew exactly where you needed to be
and you were guided the entire way
around support from the people in
Cambridge was amazing obviously it's a
lovely run itself
it was very very nice surroundings that
you were running through it's gonna be
really tough act to follow
I mean
yesterday in general was a very tough
act to follow in that I am shattered
today I am so tired it doesn't help that
pixel girls a teacher so we get up a
teacher o'clock every day but I feel
like I could sleep for 12 hours
III am absolutely white and try to force
myself to work today it's been very very
hard I'm not running today of course and
I'm not gonna run tomorrow I was I think
I'll try a run on Wednesday we'll see
how that goes but then we've got that
it's the second half of the mathematic
it back on it and that's gonna be harder
than I think I I anticipated it to be
this is gonna be tough first half done
though and that's like a thousand pounds
raised for just that race so I feel very
lucky to know what to do that yesterday
all right I'm gonna get these quavers
and try and do some work thank you very
much for watching there are wrong choice
but done on
[Music]